cette fine c'est cyril hanouna vous êtes
en direct sur ces mythes
oui mais sur la tête de ma mère
sur ces huit touches pas à vos pinceaux
en direct dès 21h 10 mais je le recevais
[Musique]
s'est passé pour dire oui pardon il est
déjà dans le plan avec vos parents oui
bonjour commissaire frichards de la dpa
ressaisi je vous appelle je suis bien au
bar la cession ou la hâte en tête du
pays
oui pardon collet espère vraiment qu'ils
étaient accusés acquittés qui fait non
mais y'a pas qui c'est qui c'est qui
c'est mais se leurrer c'est pas ta voix
bizarre mais ça tout de suite que c'est
une blague bien sûr que tu fais une voix
bizarre ou alors ça le plus normale
possible cardio celui-là
[Rires]
ça commence à monter là alors on n'a pas
si ça m'énerve redknapp est le paradis
du couscous hockey et on est déjà le
personnage surgi d'onex des rats allô
oui le paradis du coach cool allô oui
mais non oui bonjour madame commissaire
option je vous appelle parce qu'on a un
petit doute là sur la clientèle vous
êtes en observation la madame halo
madame madame c'est le commissaire berck
amant dans là ils sont tranquilles je
crois que le temps est doux spécialistes
sont ces deux organes alors viens avec
moi je suis avec une amie ce que je dis
qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on va
faire
ah bah voilà allô oui la caravelle oui
bonjour désolé nous dire en léger le
commissaire richard
je vous appelle concernant une affaire
le diabolo fraise et de trafic de
diabolo menthe dans tout le
allô allô bonjour madame pardon excusez
moi
là on est un petit peu dans l'excitation
policière vous m'entendez la wii voilà
on a un petit problème nadal il ya une
personnes malfaisantes qui douanes dans
votre restaurant qui c'est qui doit être
actuellement avec une personne masculine
est ce que c'est bien le cas madame
maillet du monde exact je suis d'accord
est ce qu'il ya une personne qui a un
comportement étrange madame on a repéré
deux personnes qui sont en fuite en est
en observation madan est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un petit indice
un porte une veste en tweed cuisez mois
de travail oui madame
alors nous aussi au travail madame s'il
vous plaît madame oui c'est c'est en
fait c'est elie semoun à l'appareil
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes en direct sur ces mythes
oui bien sûr sur la tête de ma mère sur
la tête de ma mère mais sur ces huit
touche pas à mon poste on en direct il
est 21h 10 et polyvalent mais je vous le
redis j'ai donné 3 millions c'est ça
c'est moi
voilà vous croyez vraiment qu'un des
gens qui vous appelle ses jeux et fois
arrive parfois que irl ans qui me alors
là c'est la femme était déjà des gens
qui se sont fait passer pour elie semoun
et c'est la nonne a eu c'est bien arrivé
en cas d'enfant alors à mon avis c'est
qu'on a déjà essayé de vous avez du sud
voilà du rac est vrai c'est quoi votre
prénom liqing justin alors tu sais ce
que je peux vous offrir un cadeau oui
qu'est ce que vous désirez en ce moment
avant noël je ne connais rien commandé
un titre très peu sucré à 4 est le
plaisir
qu'est ce qui me ferait plaisir à aller
un iphone d'être un smartphone 1
pourquoi pas marc renoux y aller c'est
pour moi c'est cadeau
il ya aussi un maillot sur le dvd des
lycées mais acheter âgées achetez vous
une telle est d'abord d'accord et c'est
vraiment noah ben je viens de comprendre
oui d'accord
vous nous connaissez vous pouvez vous
décrire et laissez-vous deux points de
décrire les commandes et notamment ouais
je vous ai vu à la télé il ya pas
longtemps sur un cubain sur un kinder
bueno
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]